les portes du Salon de l'agriculture se
sont refermées dimanche dernier à Paris
en parallèle se déroulait également le
Concours Général Agricole un événement
qui récompense notamment les meilleurs
produits de chaque département notre
territoire n'est pas en reste avec par
exemple 21 vignerons récompensés en
Loir-et-Cher ou trois charcutiers tours
en jours mais d'ailleurs pour la qualité
de leur rillettes mais quel crédit
accordé à ces médailles ont-elles
réellement un impact sur les ventes de
ceux qui les décrochent on fait le point
avec Sarah gros
28 hectares de vignes auquel Thomas
Piché doit s'arrêtant depuis 1995 le
domaine du petit bon Dieu exploite les
terres de restignée et n'en est pas à sa
première médaille de l'or de l'argent et
du Bronze depuis 2018 des prix en nombre
et des ventes qui explosent au fil de
aller en l'espace de de
on va dire une dizaine d'années on a on
a doublé même voir plus pratiquement
triplé le nombre de bouteilles vendues
au domaine
donc ça c'est c'est une progression mais
je vous dis encore une fois c'est
difficile de dire que c'est uniquement
grâce aux médailles parce qu'on en a pas
tous les ans non plus une chose est sûre
pour obtenir un prix